she did something very interesting in
the first week she decided not to put
her music on streaming services and I
know you're not a fan of it as well do
you think was a smart move for her to do
that and with your album coming out have
you changed your attitude towards
streaming services
I guess swiftie being one of the biggest
stars in the world it kind of would mean
more I'm not sure Spotify would give a
fine if I'd refuse to put my out on
Spotify they'd probably be like who
again to say that you know you got to
play the game these days the always
outspoken no Gallagher is ready to play
ball with the big boys and come November
24th his new album who built the moon
will give fans a glimpse into the mind
of the former Oasis frontman the first
song I listened to was Fort Knox and I
know that was inspired by Kanye West has
he heard the song at this point I would
think almost certainly not he doesn't
know me so but if you're watching Kanye
would almost certainly are if you want
to put a little rap on it be my guest I
was watching some raw footage too of
fans watching you on stage and you sing
champagne supernova and the reaction was
all the fans were singing along
[Music]
do you miss that element of Oasis the
fact that your music spoke to so many
people no cuz we did it we did it we
weren't the kind of bands that had not
fulfilled our potential we've done it so
not really I still I still got the songs
I still get to play the songs and if I
felt I was in erases for 20 odd years so
we didn't there's nothing left in the
tank I mean what if they asked you do
the Super Bowl would you do it there's
not many surefire guarantees in life but
I can guarantee you a thousand present
this that the Super Bowl will not be
coming to me I don't think there is
ideas that there may be a biopic on
Oasis and apparently mr. bean would be
fitting for you because you're so funny
apparently well I think you'll find
Morgan Freeman will be playing me like
that Ozzy Osbourne I would like as well
what will it take to call it truce
between you and your brother Liam I've
made my peace of it now it's kind of
like we're all big boys but with Noel
Gallagher and the high flying birds
filling the void the music continues to
be his legacy what would you say has
been the biggest achievement still being
around I think every record that I make
it's some kind of achievement they're
not you're not supposed to be making
records like this when you're 50 it's
supposed to be feathering your own nest
and and looking after your legacy